Oh,
and the biggest one is mindset.
You know,
to me,
the thing that has really become
fascinating,
you know,
the reason there's not a lot of content
that I put out between 2011 and 2014 if
you go back and look at the Internet,
is because I needed to go run and build
vayner media again for myself.
Because after writing crush it and
speaking a little bit from 2009 to 2011,
I was starting to get into a place where
people were talking about me and calling
me a speaker or a motivational speaker
and author,
an author,
which is super fine and an incredible
thing to do.
Uh,
but for me,
my pride isn't being a practitioner and
being an entrepreneur and being a ceo,
I needed to build a nother hundred
million dollar plus business.
Really,
to be frank with you,
I need to feel comfortable standing here
and spitting my 2 cents on things.
I think that you need to have an
execution other than ideas to have the
audacity to stand up here and expect
people to waste her time and money
listening to what you have to say.
And so I'm proud that over the last six
years I've been executing vayner media.
And while I do this Gary v thing,
Gary Vaynerchuk,
the CEO of $150 million holding company
from scratch is exciting and
interesting.
And it really has become obvious to me
why that's happening.
And it's around mindset.
I,
I think that there's way too many people
in this audience that are in the excuse
business.
I've,
uh,
and yeah,
and it's,
and it's tough because I'm empathetic.
There's always things,
you know,
you could have two parents that were
drug addicts.
You could have lost your parents in a
car accident when you were a kid.
You could have had your money stolen to
you by a partner.
There's so many things that happen in
life.
I'm super empathetic to it.
The ultimate problem is though,
is that the market,
the world doesn't care right there.
There's so much dwelling going on.
So many reasons why not.
And the thing that has been really
interesting to me is that if you asked
me what works for me,
it's optimism and gratitude and positive
mindset.
Like it's really interesting to me.
Life is pretty binary.
It's either black or white.
It's either yes or no.
And the one that matters to me the most
is you're either on the offense in your
life right now or you're on the defense.
You're either coming up with reasons why
not all this technology,
all this stuff.
Then why not?
Or why,
yes,
all this technology,
all this stuff.
You're looking at things and you're
making a decision.
And so for me,
a lot of what I've been thinking about
is mindset and why optimism works.
Literally seven minutes ago in the,
in the green room,
I'm on the phone with executives at
vayner media.
I'm getting texts of a scope that we
expect it to sign.
Failed million dollars,
literally counting out $1 million gone.
Zero not happening.
Right?
Another pitch we went to final to $8
million,
didn't get it.
Literally in 47 second step back in the
back room.
I lost $9 million
and I'll be very frank with you.
I'm fucking pumped about it.
I genuinely like losing.
I like learning from it.
I was like thinking about like why?
What happened,
where we go,
where it was,
the MISSTEP,
why?
Like it's really incredible and look
when you can afford to lose it.
And I'm sure people are thinking is it's
easier.
I get,
it's not like I lost 9 million beaner
loss,
9 million revenue,
but to me it's not about anything other
than mindset.
And so if I got anything out of this,
I'll go into the tactics.
I'll talk to you about social in a
minute.
I'm about to tell you why facebook and
Instagram,
you know,
did a lot of homework on Saturday about
the Australian market.
On my thesis is around influencers,
Instagram,
facebook,
and snapchat.
Let me save you a lot of time.
Everything that you've been hearing me
talk about,
how many people here are consumed my
content?
Raise your hands.
Thank you.
That was awesome.
Just going to do that again.
How many people here are consuming
content?
So here's what's interesting.
Literally everything that I'm spitting
comes obviously from an American centric
point of view.
That's where I operate.
Obviously we have a UK office,
we're looking at Singapore,
we're doing other things,
but I'm aware that outside of Russia and
men mainly and shine them most,
most of the stuff that actually works,
maybe there's a couple of different
nuances.
What fascinates the shit out of me is
the consumption patterns of the
Australian and New Zealand market and
the underpriced nature extremities of
what I believe in.
Literally everything that I've been
talking about for the last year,
you can add a additional 20 to 40% tax
of upside.
It is literally 20 to 40% even better in
this market.
And I get so pissed when people are in
any police besides the u s market or
China where they're like,
well,
it's a smaller market.
It's this,
that and the,
that's where all the upside is.
You can only compete against what you
can compete against.
Right?
And so I believe that we are living
through the greatest era to be an
entrepreneur ever.
I think the Internet is grossly
underestimated and I think there's a ton
of opportunity,
but if you asked me what I would want to
leave with from this talk today,
it's to shift one or two persons
mindsets.
You know?
To me it's an incredible feeling to
stand up here and expect nothing from
nobody and take full responsibility for
everything.
I the Teleco company that gave it to us
and we lost it and weed in the backroom,
the 8 million.
I spent zero days in,
zero seconds on it.
I was not part of the pitch.
I was not part of the process.
I empowered on my people.
I saw the news in the back room and I
took full 100% blame and responsibility.
I am fascinated by your upbringing,
both your parents and the neighborhood
and those siblings and the friends.
I am fascinated by your upbringing,
the era you grew up in,
the macro and micro that you grew up in,
not the fucking weather.
I mean the economics and the politics
and that climate.
I'm fascinated what made me my mom,
my dad being an immigrant from Russia,
being in America,
being in Jersey like like the friends I
ran into,
baseball cards becoming popular,
allowing me to sell something.
I'm fascinated the environment that
created me in this completely emotional
place of enormous strength,
which is the engine and the oxygen that
allows me to be successful in business
and life and then what is it that other
people don't have or didn't have?
And I see it.
I see how my grandmother parented my
dad.
I see my sisters and brothers DNA
different than mine.
You know,
just timing and things of that nature.
And so I'm going heady for my opening
spot because I need you to understand
too many of you are going to take
fucking notes right now and think it's
about a facebook ad to many of you are
about to take a note and be like,
okay,
Google how to use instagram influencers.
We'll get to that.
I'm about to talk about that.
But if your foundation isn't right,
you have no shot of longterm success.
If you're not in a place where you
believe this and look,
this is super like I'm even like
throwing up on my,
to be very frank,
here's what's happening in my head.
I'm listening to what I'm seeing right
now.
I'm like,
this fucking sucks.
I'm being serious.
I'm being really fucking serious with
you actually,
and I'm seeing that because I'm like,
man,
it's so hot.
What I'm talking about is like so hard
to like touch,
right?
But it's still my truth.
It's what I believe.
Like you're either on the offense or
you're on the defense.
You either see all these technologies as
the gateway drug to your entire future
or you're upset that it was much easier
to do this on email and seo and you
don't like this social media thing,
right?
I don't like these new things either.
I built my dad's business from a three
to a $60 million business on email and
Google ad words.
I didn't want youtube to come along.
I didn't want twitter to come along,
right?
I didn't want facebook to come along.
I didn't want snapchat to come along.
I don't want a voice and Alexa skills
and podcast to come along.
I'm not looking forward to Vr.
The problem is technology and the way we
live doesn't care about my opinion or my
feelings.
And it doesn't care about yours either.
And so you can walk around earth and
judge,
oh,
it's so sad that all these kids can't
communicate because they're on the phone
anymore.
Or you can walk out tonight and have
dinner and see people at a table and
nobody's talking to each other and
they're all on the phone and your
judging.
And you could talk about a day and age
when it was simpler and nicer and all
this.
Nobody gives a fuck.
And if you don't adjust to the reality
of the situation,
you will be completely left behind.
And that's it.
Too many people are executing or hoping
or trying to figure out how to live in a
world that used to be or the way they
wish it was versus attacking the reality
of the world.
And here is the reality of the world.
My friends,
the cell phones that you're all holding
right now or in your pocket or the
remote controls of our society,
they are the single most important thing
in the world.
There's nothing close.
Literally,
literally,
I would rather have somebody roll up on
me right now,
stab me with a knife and steal my wallet
than lose my phone.
The world is being lived through that
device and you can judge it.
You can do anything you want,
but that's the reality and if you sit
here today and have any ambitions
professionally,
personally,
whether you want to sell a course,
whether you want to sell a sneaker,
whether you want to raise money for the
PTA or nonprofit gets somebody elected,
whatever you want to happen in life,
you first need somebody's attention and
then you need to tell them about it in
the written word,
in audio or video.
This is how the world works and always
has.
You want something to happen.
You need to figure out where the people
are to tell them about that thing and
then you need to communicate that to
them.
In a compelling enough way that they do
the thing that you want them to do.
You can do that in the written word.
You can do that in audio and you can do
that in video.
That is how it's been.
It was called the newspaper,
the television and the radio.
Now it's called a blog of blog or a
podcast.
It's the same thing.
Nothing's changed except one thing.
Your attention is moving to a new place
and leaving an old place.
The other thing is we have not figured
out the creative strategies to be
successful in this world.
The other thing is there's a lot of
people in here who are not self aware
and don't realize they should only be
writing and not making videos because
they're not good at it or reversed or
reverse these blanket statements that
everybody needs a personal brand or
everybody should be doing video.
That is ludicrous.
What everybody should be doing is
deploying self awareness and figuring
out who they are.
Quadrupled Downing on what they're
fucking good at and trying to get
resources to support the stuff they suck
at.
I've written four.
Thank you.
I've written,
thank you.
I've written for,
you know,
when she was like,
he's written for New York Times best
selling books.
I literally was laughing as I was about
to get to the stairs.
I'm like,
I can't put two fucking sentences
together if my life depended on it,
but I know how to hire a ghost writer
and I definitely know how to sit down
for nine hours straight and record a
book in one fucking sitting.
Right.
You need to figure out how you
communicate to the world as an executer,
which medium.
Some of you could do all three.
Some can do too,
but watch what's been happening over the
last 10 years.
In 2000 or 15 in 2002 to four it was the
era of the blog.
It was bloggers.
How many people here were a blogger from
2002 to 2005 at any point,
raise your hands.
So some of these early piners like they
felt the impact,
right?
Right.
You were blogging.
That was it.
That was the medium.
Wordpress or you know,
even going back further,
like it was just a very important
medium.
Youtube had been yet to be invented.
You know,
it costs too much to stream video
online.
There was no video players.
Podcasting then came in 2005 and six had
a little blip,
but then write quickly after that,
twitter came out,
youtube came out and everything shifted
to short form writing and video,
right?
And then in the last two years,
audio has risen again.
How many people here now listen to a
podcast?
Raise your hands.
How many of those hands did not listen
to a podcast three years ago?
Raise your hands.
Hold them up.
Actually,
you know what?
Watch this for visual.
We're gonna do this one more time.
How many people watched how many people
are listening to a podcast now?
Raise your hands.
I want people in the front to look
around.
See what I see?
All right,
an insane amount.
Now of those people,
of the people that now listen to a
podcast,
stand up.
If you did not listen to a podcast three
years ago
and you'd be look around because if you
want to understand why I'm standing on
this stage right now,
I didn't say sit down.
I'll just get him,
get him,
get a kitty cat
if you want to understand why I'm so
blessed to sit on the stage is I have a
unique uncanny.
I take no credit.
My parents get all the credit ability to
slowly understand what you're about to
do before you think you're going to do
it.
And so what I do is when I know
something's coming,
I have humility and this is a word that
I would love for people to look up,
understand,
and start really becoming religious
about for all my ego and peacocking,
for the ones in here who've been paying
attention,
it is my humility that has allowed me to
be successful,
not in the way that I interact with you
and being kind,
because that's kindness in the humility
that when I believe something new is
emerging,
I take the perceived risk of going there
first,
spending countless hours with no clear
Roi in the short you,
many people in here have left ungodly
amounts of money because when social
came along,
they said,
well,
what's the Roi of facebook and twitter?